[Music]
on this monday night canada's capital
under a state of emergency
after 11 days police are finally taking
action attempting to clear protesters we
are turning up the heat in every way we
possibly can his appeal for help to cut
off funding and fuel and the injunction
to stop the horns plus we look at
foreign influence on the protest we need
to be very vigilant about external
forces that funds which are being
collected are not used for inappropriate
purposes also tonight high stakes
meeting over ukraine
the french president visits moscow his
message to the russian president and
canada's golden hour how one athlete's
come back from cancer led to gold
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a number of angles
on the rapidly evolving situation in the
nation's capital on this 11th day of
what the city's police chief calls an
occupation
a judge has issued an interim injunction
to halt the honking and last night for
the first time police officers began to
dismantle some of the structures built
by the protesters seizing some of the
diesel fuel containers issuing tickets
making a handful of arrests and towing
some vehicles but ottawa's police chief
says he needs more help
we are stretched to the limit but we are
100 committed to using everything we
have to end this demonstration we cannot
do it alone
late today prime minister justin trudeau
took part in an emergency debate in the
house of commons he said the protest
organizers are intent on blocking
democracy and the economy
this pandemic has sucked
for all canadians
but canadians know
the way to get through it
is to continue listening to science
continuing to lean on each other
continuing to be there for each other
democracy in canada
didn't happen by accident
and it won't continue
without effort
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is watching developments david
well donna there are fewer protesters
than there were a few days ago but those
that are here they've got access to food
funds and fuel and so the battle now is
to interrupt those supply lines we're
going after the fuel
police on sunday night cleared out a
supply depot of fuel and food that
protesters had built near the city's
downtown several arrests were made the
energy around the protest almost
immediately changed we saw it in the
live streams where individuals
you know we're almost shocked
that you know the police have taken
action and we're trying to rationalize
it but on monday our cameras caught
protesters still running a refueling
operation for the truck's park near
parliament hill people like me will come
an hour away or two hours away and we'll
bring the fuel and that's all we'll do
we'll keep at it they're going to try to
find every way to slow us down to
make us disband or
drop our morale
it's not going to work while other
protesters played decoy
so is that an empty one
some cans had juice or water others were
empty all just to confound police at
city hall a day after declaring a state
of emergency the mayor and council are
asking for another 1500 police and
civilian personnel it was unclear what
they'll get
all the federal government offered
monday was a promise of more talk with
the province and the city that this is
simply building upon the active and
ongoing conversation collaboration and
coordination meanwhile in an ottawa
courtroom late today a judge granted an
injunction sought by some people who
live downtown to order those protesters
to stop using their air horns that order
will be in place for 10 days but we have
talked to some already donna who plan to
keep on honking
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks well
people who live and work in downtown
ottawa have had it with that endless
blaring of horns and the disruption even
harassment from some protesters and now
the police arson unit is investigating
whether someone tried to start a fire
inside the lobby of a nearby apartment
building as ross lord reports it's
ignited fear in residents who say it
feels like they are under siege
it was shortly after 5 am sunday when
two men entered this ottawa apartment
building and started a fire terrifying
actions captured on surveillance cameras
residents say it happened about an hour
after they confronted protesters
verbally about noise outside the
building i was up between three and five
from the sounds of the honking i
couldn't sleep like many other residents
this woman says she's afraid to be
identified in case she's singled out and
targeted matthias munoz is an exception
this is a perfect example of
the situation that can arise when this
kind of like lawlessness happens even
more shocking is this section of the
surveillance video there is evidence of
somebody taping our door shut
so somebody came in tried to light a
fire and basically lock all of us in
here allegations that someone tried to
start a fire in this building lobby are
driving a new edge between residents and
the protesters and nerves are wearing
thin did you just like wake up and find
the first person with a flag and try and
blame them for everything i'm blaming
the culture and the environment so
what's that that that you hear the event
that you're participating in has created
one of constant harassment intimidation
and threats both men in this exchange
declined to be interviewed we're
concealing the identity of residents who
say they're afraid their homes have
become targets
this is really the scariest day that
i've i've had
here
or ever
global news spoke to a woman who
encountered the man in the lobby she
says one of them told her i'm a
protester i support the protest as the
ottawa police arson unit investigates
some residents say they're so shaken
they've decided to sleep elsewhere they
say the lobby could easily have caught
fire leading to loss of life there's a
lot of
well-meaning people out there trying to
fight for what they believe in i don't
agree with it but there are bad actors
that come out of the woodwork in these
kind of situations while sleep has been
in short supply for the last 11 days
residents hope for peace in coming days
as they await an outcome
ross lord global news
ottawa
oh what's happening on the streets of
ottawa is plain to see what is less easy
to discern is who is funding and who is
influencing this protest what's clear is
it's not all coming from within canada
everyone from former u.s president
donald trump to senator ted cruz have
weighed in on the trucker convoy it's
getting lots of coverage on right-wing
media in the u.s jackson proskow
explores who is backing this protest
with money and moral support
tensions are boiling over across our
northern border on conservative cable
news channels the protest dominates the
attempts to try and crush down on this
protest in ottawa has made it a rallying
cry following suit republican
politicians and even a former president
have taken up the cause we want those
great canadian truckers to know that we
are with them all the way global
interest in the ottawa protest is being
driven by the powerful american right
with claims of big tech censorship
adding a new layer to their efforts
after gofundme shut down the trucker's
online fundraising campaign their
corporate communists are stealing money
i mean this is literally theft by
deception
it all puts ottawa at the center of the
american culture wars which may have
been the strategy all along when u.s
based groups took notice in the early
days the scale of the level of donations
and the the international interest too
seems to be quite unprecedented kieran
o'connor is a researcher in online
extremism he says interest in the
canadian trucker protest and its
anti-government anti-mandate message has
since spread worldwide at a phenomenal
pace i was able to find evidence of
international support for the original
gofundme link from groups in communities
outside of canada i was able to find
evidence of the gofundme being shared
amongst white supremacist communities on
telegram and after gofundme pulled the
plug an alternative fundraising campaign
raised nearly 5 million dollars in just
a few days
many of those donations purport to be
from the u.s many more are anonymous we
need to be very vigilant
about
external forces about foreign
interference
and that
that funds which are being collected are
not used for inappropriate purposes
which may indeed undermine public safety
taken with the statements from american
elected officials the former u.s
ambassador to canada sees reason for
serious concern well there's a group now
within the republican party that sees
this differently
and is willing to go cross what i
consider to be a red line
and that red line is to be promoting
disruptive activity
in our neighbor friend and allies
backyard those efforts are no longer
limited to supporting the canadian
protests efforts to recreate the ottawa
convoy and its disruption are now
underway here in washington in cities
across the u.s and right around the
world
donna jackson prosco in washington
thanks public health restrictions
continue to ease in parts of this
country tonight in quebec theaters
concert halls and sporting venues are
among the businesses now allowed to
reopen at half capacity with a maximum
occupancy of 500 that limit increases to
1 000 for outdoor events proof of
vaccination is still required and more
restrictions are scheduled to be lifted
next week
in newfoundland and labrador bars and
restaurants are now able to open at 50
capacity cinemas and performance spaces
can operate at 25 capacity they're not
allowed to serve food or drinks funerals
weddings and other religious and
cultural ceremonies can go ahead with a
limit of 50 people or 25 percent
capacity whichever is less
financial aid is on the way for british
columbia's agricultural industry three
months after floods and landslides
devastated parts of the province the
provincial and federal governments will
provide 228 million dollars in recovery
and restoration funding to farmers and
ranchers who suffered losses
i do know that um
this has been a very trying time and so
with that in mind we're looking at the
serious cases in front of us and making
sure that they those checks roll out
asap
farmers can now apply for money to cover
expenses including animal welfare
repairs and restoration of land and
perennial plants like blueberries damage
from the disaster is estimated to be
about 285 million dollars with upwards
of 1100 farms affected
the push for a peaceful solution over
ukraine coming up the french president's
message to russia's president
efforts are continuing to find a
diplomatic solution to the tension over
ukraine french president emmanuel macron
met the russian president in moscow
today his message the west wants to
avoid war and build trust it's one of a
series of meetings aimed at cooling
tensions redmond shannon reports
touchdown in poland for five u.s
military planes monday carrying some of
the 3 000 extra american troops being
deployed to nato's eastern edges in
response to russia's military buildup
along ukraine's borders
russia could be able
to actually have sufficient forces for a
serious invasion by the end of this
month moscow denies it will invade
ukraine yet a flurry of diplomacy is
aiming to prevent it world leaders and
key players meeting in washington kiev
and moscow
in the russian capital french president
emmanuel macron meeting with vladimir
putin
no breakthrough after talks but the
russian president described their
meeting as useful he wants nato to stop
its expansion east and to prevent
ukraine from joining nato something
experts say is not imminent anyway
macron repeated nato's red lines on
ukraine being allowed to determine its
own future the bloc is proposing
measures on arms control in the region
instead putin is likely more trusting of
macron their two countries along with
germany and ukraine have been speaking
on and off for eight years to try and
resolve the fighting in eastern ukraine
it's the only format where russians talk
to ukrainians um and so that's the way
to bring the ukrainians at the table
good afternoon german chancellor olaf
schultz in washington where u.s
president joe biden repeated his threat
of heavy sanctions if russia invades
there will be no longer a north stream
too we will bring an end to it but olaf
schultz stopped just short of naming
germany and russia's nordstrom 2 gas
pipeline as a sanction on the table and
we will not taking different steps we
will do the same steps emanuel macron
heads to kiev where he meets with his
ukrainian counterpart vladimir zelinski
tuesday germany's foreign minister is
also heading to the front lines of the
ongoing conflict in eastern ukraine
donna
all right redmond shannon in london
tonight thanks chinese tennis star pong
shui made in its surprise appearance as
a spectator at the beijing winter
olympics on the weekend she also met
with members of the international
olympic committee though the ioc is not
commenting on whether she's able to
speak and move about freely
we as a sports organization are doing
everything to ensure
that she
is happy and i don't think it's up for
us to be able to judge in one way or
another her position
in an interview with the french
newspaper pong denied she accused a top
chinese official of sexual assault in a
social media post in november she says
it was all an enormous misunderstanding
and the post which was quickly pulled
was taken out of context the 38 year
old's whereabouts and well-being were a
mystery for weeks before she resurfaced
snowboarding survivor ahead why this
canadian olympian's greatest victory may
not have been at the games
it was a big day for canadian athletes
at the winter olympics in beijing
quebec native kim bhutan won bronze in
the women's 500 meter short track speed
skating event this is her fourth olympic
medal she won sri at the 2018 winter
olympics in south korea
team canada also won bronze in the
olympic debut of mixed team ski jumping
it's also this country's first ever
medal in any ski jumping event
making the win even sweeter the
four-person team was not even considered
a metal contender going into the event
and three is the magic number for
canadian snowboarder mark mcmorris he
was among three canadians to enter the
men's slope style final and he nabbed
his third bronze medal for the event for
his third olympics in a row he wasn't
the only canadian on the podium we'll
have more on that in a moment
first the metal standings team canada is
behind the russian athletes competing
under the russian olympic committee flag
we have six medals now including one
gold and that single canadian gold
belongs to snowboarder max perrault who
took the top spot in the slopestyle
final it's his first olympic gold an
award most athletes might consider their
greatest achievement that's not the case
for him just months ago he overcame an
even tougher event the fight for his
life
mike delay explains
max perot called this the run of his
life the moment he landed his final jump
he knew he had a good chance at gold
and then his dream came true but what a
nightmare it was to get here
after winning silver in the 2018 olympic
games perrault's world came crashing
down announcing to the world he was
diagnosed with hodgkin's lymphoma a type
of blood cancer forcing him to undergo
12 rounds of chemotherapy over the next
six months it's a challenge i've never
faced before he was fighting for his
life yet he now says the hardest part
was not being able to hit the slopes it
was actually really hard times with me
at that time i felt like i was a lion in
a cage because i wasn't able to do what
i love the most which is snowboarding um
you know i've been snowboarding since
i'm nine years old and that was the
first time in my life that i had to put
the snowboard in a closet two months
after getting a clean bill of health he
wasn't just snowboarding again he was
back competing
and winning
he was still the same max living life to
its fullest but he says he now smiles
twice as much and he no longer puts the
same type of pressure on himself in
competitions you know as a person you
know i used to take life for for granted
before as well and i don't anymore so
every time i strap my feet on my
snowboard
i appreciate so much more than than
before considering where he was exactly
three years ago nothing seems to be
weighing him down anymore least of all
that shiny new gold medal
mike delay global news toronto
you are the enemy the people you're the
vile liars
next the threats to journalists and to
democracy
we are two years into this pandemic and
everyone is exhausted people are lonely
people have lost loved ones they've lost
jobs others are overworked the
coronavirus has killed more than 5
million people around the world 5
million it's hard to comprehend and it's
understandable some people are angry and
want someone to blame politicians public
health officers and the media are all
targets but on the streets in canada
over the last 11 days
things have been said that i thought i'd
never hear in this country
a state of emergency in canada's capital
the city center paralyzed by people
demanding freedom profane insults
directed at the prime minister
the organizers calling for parliament to
be dissolved
how did it come to this
there is a lot to dissect about this
protest and it's important to point out
not everyone is this angry but one
thing's clear we no longer have an
agreed set of facts and journalists
trying to listen to protesters concerns
have become targets
how can you sleep at night with all the
the
lies
themselves it's as if they've forgotten
canada is free if you refuse to tell the
truth they can walk down the street
hurling insults
canadians have political rights and
civil liberties we have democratically
elected governments free and fair
elections and a free press
freedom of thought belief opinion and
expression including freedom of the
press is protected by the charter of
rights and freedoms
yet in toronto this happened to a global
news reporter after your convictions
your executions cannot come soon enough
you are the enemy the people you're the
vile liars
where have we heard that before
a few days ago i called the fake news
the enemy of the people and they are
they are the enemy of the people
when the former u.s president first said
that it sounded shocking
now we hear it on canadian streets
maria ressa an investigative journalist
and co-winner of the 2021 nobel peace
prize
warns of a slide into fascism enabled by
technology
our greatest need today
is to transform that hate and violence
the toxic sludge that's coursing through
our information ecosystem prioritized
by american internet companies that make
more money by spreading that hate
and
triggering the worst in us
triggering the worst in us
we are all tired of public health
restrictions when and how to loosen them
is worth civil debate
this is not that
ressa and others believe there is an
insidious manipulation happening at
scale and we're only beginning to wrap
our heads around it
as she says without facts you can't have
truth without truth you can't have trust
without trust we have no shared reality
no democracy
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen your canada
tonight is the peace tower on parliament
hill in ottawa
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you